years ago when I first met God a great
Bible teacher was teach beginning
teaching me the Bible I didn't know
anything about it said if you don't do
anything else read a proverb a day
there's 31 of them so you can do the
whole book of Proverbs in a month it's
the book of wisdom if you just read it
over and over again you'll get wiser not
only will you grow spiritually but
you'll get wiser and if you're not I
read it I mean grasp it understand it
think about it meditate on it whatever
right learn what the words mean and then
apply them oddly enough if you read the
book of Proverbs over and over again you
will have a master's degree in finance
it is all in there everything you need
to know so I do that generally read a
proverb a day and I have for thirty
years probably something like that and
it's interesting how I seek different
things as I go through the different
phases of my life and I'm going through
the exact same words but I see different
things through those same words
depending on what's going on it's a lot
different when you've got teenagers and
when you've got grandkids as an example
and proverbs 13 today right and verse 14
says the teaching of the wise is a
fountain of life that one may turn away
from the snares of death the reward of
wisdom and good planning in other words
is a fountain of life and when you think
about the context of money on this you
reap the benefits of prudence when an
emergency comes you're ready and you've
done stuff like gotten insurance in
place gotten your emergency fund in
place and you've got a good defense in
your financial plan that you know
because when the snares come the
problems come the traps come you can
avoid them and I walking around without
any health insurance is the number one
cause of bankruptcy walking around
without car insurance is the number one
cause you losing a car you know so
there's some basic stuff you got to do
and so I mean what if you had a four
hundred dollar emergency today
how would that if
you what if a window breaks your car
won't start
you got a doctor's visit it's 400 bucks
61% of Americans say they could not
answer the call for a $400 emergency
that's 6 out of 10 that's not poverty
people that's everybody
not even $400 the other thing you can do
is of course make sure you're covered
with the right kinds of insurance get
your emergency fund in place maybe step
1 get your $1,000 emergency fund to get
started with a beginner emergency fund
now our team wanted to make sure that
you figure out what coverages you've got
figure out what these basic things are
that give you a defense against these
snares traps of life and it's weird when
you've got all the proper insurance in
place not a gimmicky stuff but the right
stuff you got your will in place you've
got your emergency fund in place when
stuff comes at you it's inconvenient
nobody likes to lose a $4,000 battle
with the heating and air cover in this
system right nobody likes to write a
check but it sure is different when
you've got the money then when you're
just go into freakout mode so we've got
a 5-minute coverage check-up tool that's
completely free in just 5 minutes you
can get a customized recommendation for
all the coverage you need text the word
checkup 233 7 8 9 that's the word
checkup 233 7 8 9 or you can go to Dave
Ramsey com slice checkup and get this
five-minute checkup as fast as you can
the deal is this I don't find people who
be it build wealth only playing defense
but I also don't find people that build
wealth only playing offense if you're
going to win you have to play defense
and offense a boxer keeps one fist up in
front of his face to block while he does
damage to the opponent with the other
foot with the other fist so you're
always blocking and swinging blocking
and swinging so you
an offense and that that's your defense
up in front of your face keeping you
from getting your block knocked off
remember those old robots we had when we
were little kids anybody old enough to
remember those things right knock your
block off and that head would pop up
when you hit it that's what happens when
you don't have the right kind of
insurance in place that's what happens
when you don't have your emergency fund
in place so what happens when you don't
have your will in place get your block
knocked off and then people go well
everything was going good until now
everything was not going good because
you were not ready because stuff is
gonna happen grandma said save for a
rainy day it's because grandma is old
enough to know that sometimes it rains
as a matter of fact it's always going to
rain sometimes something's going to
happen you need that Gok fund that God
Only Knows Fund crap is coming you got
to get ready
you need your emergency fund you need
your insurance in place you've got to
play defense but that's all you ever do
and then you don't use that defensive
position to do some offensive strikes
like investing that's fine but you can't
invest and earn enough to be stupid you
can't out earn your stupidity you will
get your block knocked off and so you
need a life insurance to take care of
your family if something happens to you
you obviously have your car and your
homeowners insurance in place if these
basic things done if you're a you know
the number you out there renting a place
right now they have zero insurance on
all your stuff you did not get a renters
policy dumb go get one today two hundred
two hundred fifty bucks and almost
everybody every state that's listening
to me right now you can cover the
contents twenty thousand dollars where
the contents for theft and fire and your
little startup I just got married
apartment situation you need contents
insurance because if you come home and
all your craps gone because of a fire or
because some bozo kick the door in and
decide you want to take all your stuff
you're just screwed you get to start
over and then you'll tell the story
about how everything was going fine
until I was a victim you weren't a
victim you were stupid you didn't have
basic insurance in place you're a victim
of your own stupidity I've done and I've
been a victim of my own stupidity I got
a PhD in D U and B I know what stupid
like I've looked at him in the mirror a
lot but you've got to get ready for
these things you've got to take the time
to stop and do stuff like this
five-minute checkup and make sure that
you're in make sure you're in tune you
know make sure you're ready and that
you're ready for bad stuff to come and
then it's not fatal when it comes it's
not financially fatal